[Music]
stephen is in phoenix hi steven welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave how you doing today better than
i deserve what's up
so
i've made it to becoming debt-free
except for my mortgage
in arizona but
we're thinking about moving to florida
and i want to know if i should sell my
house in arizona and pay off on cash in
florida
uh
if you're moving to florida yes
okay what's the sole purpose of that
question are you moving to florida just
for cheaper housing or are you moving
for for purpose for professional for
family what's going on
so i run a crypto mining business out of
my house here but i'm in an hoa
and we're looking for states that are
i guess more leaning towards the red
side more freedom
oriented but
i just have to convince my wife
to sell our house here because we
currently have a mortgage
to just pay for one cash
out right in florida
without an hoa
so i can grow the business as well
have you done your homework on a
specific spot in florida that you got in
mind here is this is this all
theoretical
no so i've done research i'm looking
north of orlando kind of near the deland
area for about
around an acre or so
is what we're looking for to set up like
a mining shed
it's just kind of convincing my wife to
get on board with the whole idea because
it's kind of like a big it feels like a
big risk
why is it a big risk
uh it's just a big change i think and
she's just worried about it um maybe the
mining business not working out in the
future because it flows with the market
so it's not always profitable
right
but that's true in arizona and in
florida
yeah exactly so so having no mortgage in
florida
while you're in an unbelievably high
risk business
would be less stressful than having a
mortgage in arizona while you're in an
unbelievably high risk business
how old are you
29
i think your wife's telling you she
doesn't like what you do for a living
for risk-wise
i think that's what's happening i could
be wrong could be some family involved
you know doesn't want to leave family i
mean this is
this is a marriage issue here this is
some communication sit down and get on
the same page are we together the
problem is is you're trying to reduce
um
your entire life
which is your relationships your church
your where you shop for groceries
um
where
you uh
how how close you are to relatives
um all of that down to a decision on
whether you have a shed
or a mortgage
and um it's not it's not that simple
there's more variables involved and even
one of the variables is it that you're
in an unbelievably high risk business
and um
the uh
your your wife um
uh uh is
i think she may be saying that to you uh
maybe she doesn't even know she's saying
that to you but that's scaring her
um because you know
but but it's not as simple as
housing's cheaper north of atlanta north
of orlando an hour than it is in phoenix
which it is but there's parts of orlando
that are not cheaper than phoenix so you
know if you go north of phoenix well not
north of phoenix but if you go outside
of phoenix an hour probably not north
towards sedona but if you go a different
direction you might find
land that's very very cheap there too
without an hoa and if you sold your
house in phoenix proper like if you're
sitting in scottsdale which is a very
expensive market you could move out of
there and probably pay cash for
something an hour outside of phoenix so
i i don't care where you live yeah and i
just want to point out that uh what it
feels like dave is that okay
this is really risky it's making my wife
nervous but i can buy some more time
to keep going with this risky business
if i remove my mortgage and i just need
a little more time and and and i i feel
like there's something there that's
that's right
and i would also point out that knows
the governor of arizona is a very very
strong liberty champion so arizona is
not
the politics in arizona florida blue
state no no they're not different so i
just want to point that out i'm trying
to take away the excuses